the news that broke prior to the draft
last night had very little to do with
the draft it was the Kansas City Chiefs
and their star player Tyree kill a
couple of weeks ago information came out
that his son three-year-old son had a
broken arm authorities called to the
house but the district attorney said no
charges were going to be filed but that
changed we said this yesterday if
there's audio if there's video if
there's pictures then it changes the
story now we have audio here is a
portion of what Tyreke kills fiance had
to say and this is her recording this
conversation and now somehow this
investigation got brought back up and
you're about to lose you now I really
want you to say and think about it
because I wrote for you against that
detective and the CPS people and they
said time and time again that literally
kept saying daddy punches which you do
when he starts crying what do you do you
make him open up his arms and you punch
him in the chest and then if he gets in
trouble you get the belt out and I told
I don't use a belt which is totally
different he was a villain s heir even
my mama says you use it whenever I used
the belt when have you seen me use about
look when have I used a belt it's
bringing a Brooke Pryor she covers the
Chiefs for the Kansas City Star how did
the team respond to this Brooke you know
last night Brett Beach came out he
wasn't scheduled to talk to us talk to
the media because that she didn't have a
first-round pick they traded that away
instead he came out and announced that
they were deeply disturbed and concerned
about the audio and that ty Reed was
suspended essentially he didn't say the
phrase the Senate suspended but he said
that he the tirade wouldn't be involved
in any team activities for the
foreseeable future
while the Chiefs gather more information
and review it and then he said we will
make the right decision regarding Tyreke
o our authorities reopening this case
have we gotten any word on that no we
haven't heard on that when we last
spoke to da Steve how I in that press
conference earlier this week they didn't
have enough to charge someone with a
crime but they believed one had occurred
they just couldn't prove who did it but
he said that if any new information came
to light that can obviously change
things and we know at this point that
they didn't have that audio at the time
of the press conference and at the time
that they decided not to charge him so
you'd have to think that this does
significantly change things TMZ reported
police were called to Tyriq Hills last
night do we know why we spoke with
Overland Park Police this morning and
they said that they were there to check
on crystal and put all the fiance who
has heard in that recording we you know
haven't heard if Tyrese Hill was even
home at that point but it was a brief
call they responded for about 20 minutes
she's currently pregnant with twins and
all of this so that says about what we
know about that call what happens today
with this team this situation Brooke you
know I don't know the team I have to say
it was a little surprising last night
that they came out and said that they
need to gather more facts and review
everything before making a decision you
know this is a team that has had a
recent history with players who have
domestic violence and and physical
violence toward women in in their
background
Kareem hunt was released just five
months ago for that video jovan belcher
in 2000 2012 the murder suicide and now
today at 2:30 they're set to introduce
Frank Clark
then when the Kareem hunt video came out
it took them about six hours to release
him obviously the fact that this is
going on during the giraffe's I think
complicates that timeline and we don't
know you know how how quickly they would
have responded had this not been going
on but with Kareem hunts they waited
until he was on the commissioners exempt
list which happened later that night
after the video came out about two
o'clock Friday afternoon he was placed
on the commissioners exempt list and he
was released I believe around 8 o'clock
and you know you hate to compare
situations because there is no
comparison
both awful but the audio that we heard
in this was more jarring sitting there
listening to it that the video that we
have seen of Korea and the whole
situation is bad obviously and so I
think that this is a team that has to
make a decision and it shouldn't be a
difficult one Brooke thank you I
appreciate your time
Brooke Pryor be writer for the Kansas
City Chiefs for the Kansas City Star
Thank You Brooke for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on VR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app